دانا رئيس الوزراء السويدي الف كريسترسون
استمرار هجمات روسيا التي وصفها بالمنهجه
على المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه المدنيه في
اوكرانيا
في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع رئيسه البرلمان
الاوروبي
روبرتمتسولا بمقر البرلمان في ستراسبورغ
اعتبر ان الهجمات الروسيه جرائم حرب وستتم
مسائله المسؤولين عنها
الحكومه السويديه
الصاروخيه التي نفذت السبت الماضي
سيتم تقديمهم للمساءله ومهما استغرق الامر
من وقت سيواصل الاتحاد الاوروبي والسويد
تقديم دعمهما الشعب ليكانيا
عن تصريحات رئيس الوزراء السويدي ماذا
ايضا تم التركيز عليه في هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي المشترك في مقر البرلمان الاوروبي
ربما امام ما جاء على لسانه رئيس الوزراء
السويدي ربما يكون الضوئي التوطيه او يعني
تمهيد لما سيدور في الجلسه التي ستنطلق
بعد اقل ساعه من الان يعني في حدود الساعه
التاسعه بتوقيت الدوحه السابعه بتوقيت
سبور هنا والتي سوف تستمع فيها يعني
البرلمان الاوروبي او اعضاء البرلمان
الاوروبي لارد المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئاسه
المجلس الاوروبي بخصوص ما اقترحاته في
قرار تبنته منذ شهر ماي الماضي هذا القرار
يدعو الاتحاد الاوروبي الى انشائي محكمه
خاصه لتتبع ما همم من يصفهم الاوروبيون
بمجرم الحرب الروس خلال هذه الحرب التي
يصفونها بالعدوانيه ضد اوكرانيا ويقولون
فيها ان المدنيين يستهدفون بما يشكل جرائم
ضد الانسانيه وجرائم حرب واضحه من قبل بضم
الروسي ما يستدعي ايجاد اليه محكمه خاصه
تسعى لانشائها اوروبا من اجل محاكمتي
المسؤولين والطالعين في هذه
الجرائم هو كما قلت لمن تم همم هذا
المقترح صياغته في قرار تبناه البرلمان
الاوروبي في مايو الماضي اردفه بقرار ثاني
في نوفمبر يعتبر فيه روسيا دوله ارهابيه
ودوله ترعى الارهاب وتستعمل اساليب
ارهابيه مطالبا الاتحاد الاوروبي خطوات من
اجل تصنيفها كدوله ارهابيه طبعا هنالك
يعني عائق يكون قانوني امام هذا لان
التشريعات الاوروبيه لا تسمح بتصنيف دوله
ارهابيه وانما تصنيف تنظيمات وذلك همم
لذلك دعى البرلمان الاوروبي في قراره الى
ايجاد اساس القانوني والاليات القانونيه
من اجل التمكن من هذا التصنيف ويبدو ان
هناك ميل هنا في زمان الاوروبي الى مساله
تتبع روسيا من اجل ما يعتبرونها جرائم حرب
وجرائم ضد الانسانيه ترتكبها في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا وهذا ما اكده رئيس الوزراء
السويدي خلال المؤتمر الصحفيه الذي جمعه
بمثلا رئيسه البرلمان الاوروبي والذي قال
فيه بوضوح ان بلاده تدين باشد العبارات
خاصه همم القصف الاخيره الذي جد السبت
الماضي همم
وتضرر فيه المدنيون وقال انه همم سوف يدفع
بقوه من خلال رئاسه بلاده لمجلس الاتحاد
الاوروبيه من اجل تتبع الرؤوس على ما
يعتبره جرائم حرب ايمان